kaa.lt
The subtitles of this video are generated by machine translation.
ON
ED
Brevin they disappeared?
Same as before when we were teleported to Yuanyuan Paradise
Where did you go this time
The annoying expansion knight has disappeared
The fortress is now ours
Then the world is also ours
Don't want to go so well
because I
Also expand the knight
Connect these two ties across the distant time
Encounter the energy of miracles
Find more exclamations than the future depicted
Get the glory with you
Regardless of the difficulties ahead
Absolutely must leap over
Can think like this
It’s because I care about this important world and my friends
Come out, refactor now
Guard you who gave me courage
Believe in your own power
No matter how many times I have to try
Although important things are always changing
But i will never run away
Swear to the core
Come on go
The end of the world
Dark thread
A little stronger, black knight
Don't think you can be what you want
I'll help you Xuan
Beni
Go Beneta
Ok
This is really interesting
Two traitors get together
Okay, give you both sanctions and real terror
What's wrong with Mr. White
I heard Sliga and the others showed up near Beham Tower.
In fact, there is a deblocking device on the Beham Tower
It is precisely because of this device that the earth can survive being completely cubed
Sligar and the others are probably aiming for this
If the device is destroyed, will the earth be completely cubed?
Yes
Planet Rubik's Cube is still in crisis
How to do
Go to Beham Tower
It would be bad if the earth was cubed
Good soldiers are divided into two ways
Qinglan and I go to Behamta
it is good
Middle yellow and ten grass go to planet Rubik's Cube
Let's go
hurry up
Ok
Why
What the hell is going on
what happened
The portal is not working
No reaction at all
How could this be
Maybe because when we came back
Was forcibly teleported back
So there is a problem with the flow of unfolding energy
What to do with red lotus
no way
I don’t know when I can teleport. It’s a waste of time to stay here.
Let's go to Beham Tower together
I know
it is good
The defense is very solid
Same as i thought
I’m afraid it’s helped by the unfolding energy emitted here
Can the earth delay the spread of cubes?
Okay, let's do it
Mr. White?
Blenox they have entered Beham Tower
Are you all together
I wanted to split the troops
One of them went all the way to the planet Rubik’s cube and found that it couldn’t go
What happened
I don’t know but everyone is rushing to Behamta together
I just need the power of the four of you
Mr. White
You said Beham Tower prevented the earth from becoming cubed.
In fact, the tower will extract the unfolding energy of the earth for purification
And then spread into the atmosphere
What a great Mr. White. Did you do it alone?
No one helps me
Someone to assist?
Our other companion
Please, I'll go to the portal room to assist you
To understanding
Please contact me when you get into the tower
it is good
This is a trap
Speak earlier
Fortunately, Lord Villius is called every day
This kind of thing burns the circuit and it is useless
What you said is true
I go first
Hi wait
red lotus
Here we are in the elevator
You go up the elevator first, and then you stay on the first floor
Why only i stay
Explain to you later
Qinglan listen to Mr. White's command
okay, I get it
Everyone moves fast
What do we do when we get on the elevator
Everyone, listen up
Although the deblocking device is fine
But due to Sliga and their invasion
The entire system of the tower is abnormal
what happened
Explain well, Mr. White
In other words, the beginning of the earth is cubed
Terrible
Although I can fix the system
But the system needs to be restarted
So you need to use the power of the blocks in the four blocks inside the tower
Qinglan, go to the building block room on the first floor
I know I'm going
But it’s useless to start Qinglan yourself
The mechanism in this room needs four people to use together to start
what
Next is Zhonghuang
Leave it to me here
Uh be careful
please
There is nothing here
Where is that device?
Lie
there's noise
hurry up
No matter how you stand on tiptoe, the elevator won't accelerate
My pleasure
So
Oh My God
Isn't this the second knight?
I'm here to catch you
Red lotus portal device
Hold it in yellow
Running around and annoying
it is good
Great
You bugs
Do some useless resistance, I can't spare you
It seems to be evenly matched over there
If this continues...
Use some energy to expand
The matter is no more
What is he going to do
Accept the unfolding energy of evil
what happened
That's right, dyed in evil colors
what
Shan Shenlong was taken away
The ink cloud covers the world...
Is the legend true...
Even the good dragon has become my servant
Expanding the fortress is mine
What to do with red lotus
Mr. White
I stop the elevator now
you guys…
Almost
hurry up
Ok
Do i stay here
and many more
Ten grass sliga, let me introduce it
I'll leave it to you here
Um leave it to me
and many more
Is there only Guren left?
Is anyone back
Damn those guys
Ah you are
Blenox
Dolibidon
hateful
Very helpful Mr. White
Block R35 blocking wall
Thank you Mr. White
Are you ready?
Um ready
Hurry up
Here too
Mr. White
Are all okay
Yes
Then the four of you put the blocks in the central device together
Guren, send a signal
Come on
One two
Brevin opens the door
Come on one or two
Ten grass slowed down
Again
Sorry everyone
Brevin open the door
Everyone do it again
One two
It’s so amazing that the whole body can feel the unfolding energy of good
What power is this
After the restart is complete, the blocks can be taken away
The blocks are glowing
what happened
Building blocks are calling us
But we can't go to the planet's cube
The blocks didn’t shine at that time
Now the flow of unfolding energy is estimated to have changed
Maybe I can go?
Yes
So happy...ah
See Mr. White
Sorry
Brevin
Dolibidon
Walloon
Leidendall
We are unfolding knights
The captain’s enemy’s attack exceeded the self-healing limit of the unfolding fortress
hateful
How do you feel? Now you two traitors are left
go to hell
he came
Waiting for a long time to expand the knight
Xuan Bei Ni sorry for waiting
Where did you go
Good dragon it!
What happened
Was swallowed by Velius’ evil unfolding energy
What can you do when you come
Good and evil dragons are in hand, our generation is invincible in the world
We no longer need to be your opponent personally
So tired
Your opponent is us
I will love you so much
let's go
it is good
What can you do if you can’t turn into the ∑ mode
Poreas
Oros
Zephyros
Nodos
Golem reconstruction
Brevin
and many more
so tired
Pay for life
You can die together hand in hand
You have no chance of winning in this form
Do we stop here
Are we going to lose
Can not give up
I wait for Spectross
Even if the battle is the last one, I will never give up
Bigger
As expected to be the leader of Spectross, the consciousness is really high
Just kill you for your courage
Run away big
go to hell
Spectros' glory is forever
stop
red lotus
It's stupid to die voluntarily
Brevin why
Why protect people like me
Sorry
How could it be that Guren...
Isn't it true
red lotus
Brevin
That just...
what happened
Is that
Holy Beast Unfolds Sirius
Candies that cannot be melted
Keep shining
The world glimpsed from the secret base
Without courage, it will not be feasible
The grassland flows like a whirlpool
Involved us in the impending unfolding
Candies that cannot be melted
Propelled by dreams that never end
Puff your cheeks with a smile
Click, click, click, click, click forward
The gear that turns where you want to go
My freedom
Polished and shiny
Expand the hero
Hi everyone i am a navigation system
What I want to introduce today is
Beham Tower
Its true identity is to prevent the coming crisis
And the block defense
Stay tuned next time
Hello everyone, I am Guren
I will never give up
To protect the two worlds I will continue to fight
This is where we unfold the knight
The beginning after the end of the next time
Rush!